foreign
I believe art is an ancient language
that we use to communicate with each
other
into the future
a year ago I took a magnificent Journey
with a friend
where I went to see some prehistoric art
we went deep into the desert of Niger to
look for art that had been created tens
of thousands of years ago
the journey was filled with long
conversations
Tuareg music and our Whimsical Shadow
dances
and lots of laughter
as we drove deep into the Sahara we
found delicate drawings scratched into
the gray rock faces art made at a time
when the Sahel was filled with people
and their cattle
full of lakes and forests and home to
hippos and giraffes
we saw Engravings of characters made
with intricate detailed patterns a sign
that whomever had carved them knew one
day they would be seen and admired
these ancient Voices From the Past spoke
of the wealth and the Bounty that
existed showing the importance of making
recording and representing ourselves
art is that ancient language that we've
been using for longer than written texts
we've left messages for each other using
art
messages that travel across the expanse
of time and culture reminding us where
we come from
as long as I can remember I've been
making art and I've always made art
about women I've created figures with
female bodies that sometimes look like
pregnant creatures or wounded and then
repaired women I've made a hybrid humans
and even Fierce feminine machines
all to show how the female body is a
powerful sight onto which culture
expresses its feelings of worthiness of
Desire or distaste
of divinity or decrepitude of belonging
or loss
the images I make like the ones I saw
carved on those ancient desert rocks are
essentially the representation of the
presence of the female
in all of us
growing up in Nairobi in the 1970s Kenya
had every appearance of a happy
wholesome modernized country
we had fought reclaimed and celebrated
our independence from a tyrannical
British rule
but there were and there still are old
skeletons and Colonial traumas rattling
in our closets
when I was 10 years old whilst our
second president was in office there was
an attempted and failed coup
the president behaved increasingly
paranoid and authoritarian and he placed
restrictions on all types of freedoms of
expression
people began to disappear
journalists preachers artists teachers
even my relatives who were vocal about
the government
began to vanish
Kenyan people were rendered invisible
small and silent
and I wanted to get out
and I did through my mind by creating
art and imagining places I could go
where I could communicate freely and
fearlessly
within a few years time I found myself
in New York and though I immediately
felt far and removed from my country
my mind remained clear and determined
because I'd carried inside of me the
language of my ancestral home
the cacophony of this big new city was
disorienting at first it was unlike
Dusty green Nairobi but with time I
found my creative Rhythm Gathering all
manner of pictures and knickknacks some
sentimental others unfamiliar collecting
discarded objects old pictures even
letters I cut and assembled them
and as I glued them together I put
myself together
slicing out pictures from magazines and
books found on the streets of the city I
transformed them into large paintings
with figures that were disjointed but
whole distorted but Strangely Beautiful
I stuck these fragments into imaginary
environments that seemed frightening and
violent but always alluring and
otherworldly
it was my way of creating order and
Grace a way to remember who and where
I'd come from
mending and healing in order to Triumph
after harvesting so much paper and
producing so so many collages
I felt it was time to step back and let
go time to purge and shred this excess
paper and these materials that I'd
collected for years
and I did
turning it all into a dark thick paper
clay which I used to create my first
large sculpture a reclining woman with
open arms and her eyes facing forward a
figure who could see a new beginning on
its way titled She's Got the Whole World
in her
as I visited and returned from my
childhood home I came back with all
types of rocks and branches
pots and Beads and each shell each bone
each feather I found I used in the work
weaving back that deep connection to my
home soil
I sculpted
these giant Earth Queens
and placed the small mementos inside of
them archiving my memories and
experiences with family and friends
our bodies once carried all of our art
our bodies are our oldest museums I made
these sculptures to represent our
fractured and remade histories and our
connection to each other and our red mud
each of them A Portrait of the
resilience and the diversity of African
women formed from these particles of
mother continent
shaped like old trees shaped like my
sisters and my grandmothers
like ant hills and women friends
like the coral reef and the Great Rift
Valley
shaped like me
I gave them large elaborate feet
so they could stand steady strong
as I spent more time reconnecting with
this home I'd come back to I conjured up
more Supernatural characters
this time in bronze
like my smooth shiny water woman a
version of the mythical guva of East
African law
a creature with the power to Delight us
to instruct or destroy us who speaks
directly to sea creatures and the water
itself
I created another sea goddess and named
her mama Ray
with mystical shall eyes that see into
the past and know the future with wings
so wide they could carry us across the
ocean
and then next I created
a great woman crocodile with striped
armor like long words cut into her body
to remind us of our land our land that
remembers us
in 2018 the Metropolitan Museum of Art
invited me to their first commission
ever to create new sculptures that would
sit in the building's facade
these niches that had remained empty for
over a hundred years
I created four seated deities
all wearing golden crowns of light robed
in Rippling bronze garments made to
reflect the Sun
the First with a bright disc over her
mouth
the second with a golden mirror on her
eyes
the third with a radiant crown
and the fourth with a circular Light
Beam on her forehead these Works stood
for tranquility dignity africanity and
The Feminine divine
a few months after they were placed in
the niches
the entire world descended into a
pandemic and it's during this time in
this crisis that the Serene Guardians
continued shining expressions of Hope
and calm and healing for us all
foreign
[Music]
this journey I began by drawing and
sculpting many different versions of
women like myself is what allowed me to
move forward it's what gave me
permission to re-examine my home and my
family and my country from a distance
it's making art that continues to remind
me what freedom I was so Desperately
Seeking for me for us for anyone who
works for our rightful place in the
future
and even if we begin our Journeys at
first to escape
the return path is always inside of us
if we want to exist in the homes we
thought we never belonged we have to
create new powerful images for them
when I'm working I know I'm using this
ancient language and I know that I'm
where this language was born
I know we have all been related for
millions in years and that we need to
take care of this one vessel that
connects us to Our Roots Our Roots in
the rift valley or the Sahara or the
shores of the Nile somewhere on African
soil where we left traces of our first
Journeys
art is that ancient language that we've
always used to remind us where we're
from and where we're heading
I hope to always make art that empowers
women
that points us to the Future
to Africa where art originated
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]